so to be honest I gave up on the debate
last night after about an hour and a
half I can give my analysis of an hour
and a half of the debate I gave up I
went down to the hotel bar because the
thing was I was expecting it to be a
two-hour debate I was mentally prepared
for two hours and then I realized about
you know halfway through that it's
actually two and a half hours and that's
when I fell into deep despair and gave
up all hope and I just had to turn it
off but from what I did see I will offer
my analysis of this very important
debate a debate which of course actually
is not important at all because they're
going to do you know 50 of these things
and nobody already you probably if you
watch the debate you already probably
can't remember 98% of it by by next week
or even by the debate tonight you're
gonna have forgotten all of it so it
really doesn't matter but here's the
first point I want to make regardless
not just about this debate but about all
debates and I'll say this when I am
dictator of the country well there won't
be any political debates when I'm
dictator because I will be the sole
lifetime supreme ruler but if there were
debates and I was in charge I would have
all the candidates standing at the
podium on like one of those like a
trapdoor that you see in some some
cartoons and the trap door would open
and they would fall into shark-infested
waters the first moment they open their
mouths to offer an anecdote there are a
few things that I hate more and I hate a
lot of things there are a few things I
hate more than anecdotes from
politicians in debates it's just it's
utterly pointless I guess they've been
told I guess they focus group didn't
they be told that some people go for
this stuff but I don't know who those
people are so it's like you know they
you know let me tell you about Roberta
Smith Roberta Smith is a crossing guard
in Iowa
she's a single mom of three her youngest
child has one leg her second youngest
child has three legs
Roberta just lost her job and she got
the flu and her car exploded and her dog
has arthritis the other thing about
Roberta and it's just look even if
Roberta exists which is debatable this
has nothing to do with anything
telling us the tragic story of some
random person
you supposedly met on the campaign trail
does not it all prove whatever point
you're trying to make and if it is a
real person so if it's a fake person
then you're lying if it's a real person
it's even worse because you are
transparently exploiting their pain
you're exploiting Roberta's pain with
her three legged child her pain and
suffering it's not like this is
spontaneous you obviously rehearsed this
it is painfully blatantly rehearsed an
anecdote meant to emotionally manipulate
the audience and it's irrelevant on top
of that and I hate it and it needs to
stop so that's the first thing is is
anecdotes we need to get rid of those
and when I am dictator anyone who offers
them will be eaten by sharks
that's my solemn pledge now that out of
the way what else we'll go through and
look at a few of the comparatively
notable events from the debate the first
thing of note the most notable thing for
me happened close to the end of the
debate but but this I really liked watch
this we we have an administration that
has gutted the Clean Water Act we have
communities particularly communities of
color and disadvantaged communities all
over this country who are suffering from
environmental injustice I assure you I
lived in Grosse Pointe what happened in
Flint would not have happened in Grosse
Pointe this is part of the dark
underbelly of American society
and the entire conversation that we're
having here tonight if you think any of
this wonkiness is going to deal with
this dark psychic force of the
collectivized hatred that this president
is bringing up in this country then I'm
afraid that the Democrats are going to
see some very dark days so that is
marianne williamson talking about the
dark psychic force of collectivized
hatred the dark psychic force of
collectivized hatred that is quite a
salad of words and by the way how do we
defeat the dark psychic force of
collectivized hatred well we have to
collect the for unity stones from the
four corners of the earth she got into
that later I don't know if you if you
might have missed that part
marianne williamson is is a sort of
lovably quirky and weird person she's
also of course wrong about just like
everybody else on the stage she's wrong
about everything and her policy ideas
are abysmal but at least she has
eccentric charm to her which is more
than I can say for most of the other
characters on the stage
aside from marianne williamson if I were
to pick for let's say takeaways from the
debate they would be this the first and
this what I thought was interesting
there are people in the Democrat Party
this may actually be a revelation to you
it was sort of to me there are still
people in the Democrat Party who know
how crazy and delusional Democrats seem
when they act like genies who can grant
you know a million wishes can grant
unlimited wishes to anyone who wants
them that was the most fascinating thing
to me in the debate watching the
relatively sane ones and there were a
few again relatively in comparison to
you know considering where the bar is
for sanity among Democrats relatively
sane watching them try to desperately
rein in the insane ones but they are
dwindling voices and of course they
stand no chance because sanity is well
outside the Democratic mainstream these
days so so that's that's what's funny is
the people who are normal relatively
normal and sane are now fringe in the
Democrat Party the ones who will get up
there and say as some had to say at the
debate look we can't just give everyone
everything the kids
give free everything that now is a
fringe idea in the Democrat Party I did
though really appreciate this moment
between Hickenlooper and Sanders I want
you to watch Hickenlooper x' facial
expression watch this the truth is that
every credible poll that I have seen has
bee beating Donald Trump including
including the battleground states of
Michigan where so you see there
Hickenlooper just openly rolls his eyes
at Bernie Sanders which is such a
perfect response to Bernie Sanders and
in that moment of rolling his eyes we
were all Hickenlooper I think we we were
Hickenlooper Hickenlooper was us he
represented us because that's how most
of us feel when we watch Bernie Sanders
it's just that's exactly like okay
Bernie all right
but this is all part again of that kind
of sad desperate losing battle that some
minority fringe members the Democrat
Party are fighting to try and keep the
party at least somewhat tethered to
reality second takeaway speaking of not
being tethered to reality last night we
got to see yet again Democrats up on the
stage on national TV seriously
sincerely advocating reparations and
this shows you where the party is let's
watch this clip here we need to
recognize that when it comes to the
economic gap between blacks and whites
in America it does come from a great
injustice that has never been dealt with
that great injustice has had to do with
the fact that there was 250 years of
slavery
followed by another hundred and hundred
years of domestic terrorism what makes
me qualified to say 200 to 500 billion
dollars I'll tell you what makes me
qualified if you did the math of the 40
acres and a mule given that there was
four to five million slaves at the end
of war of
now fortify and they were all promised
40 acres and a mule for every family of
four if you did the math today it would
be trillions of dollars and I believe
that anything less than 100 billion
dollars is is an insult and I believe
that 200 to 500 billion is is
politically feasible today because so
many Americans realize there is an
injustice that continues to form a
toxicity underneath the surface and
emotional turbulence thank you very much
keep in mind this would have been as is
the case with so many things are here
from Democrats in these days this would
have been unthinkable even certainly ten
years ago even five years ago just like
it would be unthinkable to have
mainstream Democrats openly advocating
socialism we were unthinkable to have
you know almost every Democrat
advocating putting men in the women's
bathroom all the stuff I've been saying
about five ten years ago and now it's
normal but openly advocating reparations
during Barack Obama was not a proponent
of reparations he opposed reparations or
rather at least Obama knew that he had
to oppose it because it was such a
wildly unpopular idea and it still is
wildly unpopular because except with the
minority of people who would receive
money as payment foreign justices that
they did not themselves suffer it of
course is unpopular there was Don Lemon
last night said I forget the exact
statistic I think he said seventy six
percent of African Americans support
reparations and the in the form of cash
payment okay well I understand it it
because of course if you go up to
somebody and you say do you support
being given cash I'm actually surprised
this only seventy six percent I think
almost everybody would say well sure
yeah I mean if you're gonna give it to
me I'll take it but everybody else it's
unpopular with it except for that the
group of people who would receive the
money and also hardcore left-wing
activists who are the ones driving the
party now third moment that I liked and
this is just a small moment but you need
to watch when we play this clip watch
Elizabeth Warren's hands watch this your
estimate
net worth is more than 65 million
dollars that would make you subject to
senator Warren's proposed wealth tax on
the assets of the richest 75 thousand
homes households or so in the United
States do you think senator Warren's
wealth tax is a fair way to fund child
care and education she I don't know if
you caught that it sort of subtle but
she's literally rubbing her hands
together like a super villain or
something when they're talking about her
confiscating money from wealthy people
that she does this she doesn't evil
little she doesn't evil grin and rubs
her hands together I mean these people
they're not even trying anymore
for finally this for me was a moment and
it was small it was kind of a glancing
moment I don't think it's something a
lot of people gonna be talking about but
I'm so fed up with mayor Pete doing this
so annoyed by it that I have to mention
it watch this here
the minimum wage is just too low and
so-called conservative Christian
senators right now in the Senate are
blocking a bill to raise the minimum
wage when scripture says that whoever
oppresses the poor taunts their maker
okay there is Bishop Pete again bringing
religion into it this guy he gives more
homilies than the Pope and he's even
more theologically off-base than the
Pope is these days the thing that takes
me off about about Pete throwing the
Bible around as he so often does is that
it's just so cynical okay
the fact is he holds many views that are
obviously totally at odds with Scripture
and he must know that on some level I
mean let's just start with the fact that
he advocates abortion through every
stage of pregnancy up until the moment
of birth now the idea that that's
Scripture the idea that Jesus would
somehow support that is clearly absurd
yet he continues to Bible thump and
that's the irony now that on the public
stage among prominent politicians mayor
Pete is pretty much the only bible
thumper he's the one true bible thumper
on the public stage
among politicians and he's a radical
left Democrat I can you I can't think of
a Republican who tries to make their
point by quoting scripture as often as
Bishop Pete does I know everybody would
would point to Mike Pence
I've Mike Pence
despite his his reputation is not up
there constantly quoting scripture
especially if he's talking about
something that is not directly related
to it
that's what Bishop Pete does and when I
say when I say that he's a bible thumper
I mean that in the sense because there's
a distinction here just because you
quote scripture doesn't make you a bible
thumper a bible thumper is someone who
just rips out a verse often out of
context and pummels his opponents with
it he uses it as a as a as a bludgeoning
tool to beat his opponents over the head
that's what a bible thumper is and
that's what conservatives are accused of
doing but that in fact is what mayor
Pete does what he says about the the
minimum wage yes the Bible is very clear
that we should not oppress the poor or
exploit the poor but the whole point
that we make here about the about the
minimum wage is that it's not oppressive
okay to to you know having no minimum
wage or if we refrain from raising it to
50 that is not oppressive that's our
where we are not advocating for
oppressing the poor that's a position
that nobody holds so this is a straw man
argument bishop Pete says oh the
Republicans should realize that the
Bible says you shouldn't oppress the
poor yes of course we all agree we
shouldn't oppress the poor the other
point that we make that is that rarely
do do people people like Bishop Pete
even engage with is that by raising the
minimum wage you hurt the poor because
now you incentivize companies to
automate these jobs which many of them
can do we've all been most of us anyway
have been in a McDonald's recently and
most McDonald's at least many of them
are across the country have these
automated things now where you just go
up and you put in your order and that's
taking away jobs if you go to McDonald's
you say you now all the cash
that are left who are doing a job that
the automated machine thing it can't can
do and is already doing now you have to
pay them $15 an hour
guess what McDonald's is gonna say
they're gonna say you know what I think
the automated things are working fine
we'll just stick with those so you hurt
the poor by doing that all right so
that's the debate a few other things
talk about before we go on I just I do
want to stop and pay um pay homage for a
moment there's recently been a movement
among Democrats in Congress to unfollow
Trump on Twitter first there was one
congressman who unfollowed Trump and he
announced it he made this very dramatic
announcement on Twitter it's explaining
why he unfollowed the president and then
Congressman Joe Cunningham of South
Carolina posted yesterday this
absolutely harrowing video he not only
unfollowed Trump but he took a video of
himself unfollowing Trump and he posted
that video can you imagine the heroism
that is required to make a stand like
that to unfollow Donald Trump on Twitter
to confine yourself to only seeing his
tweets when everybody else retweets them
and when the media covers them yeah I I
just I could only dream of having a
tenth of this man's strength and courage
it's it's truly generations down the
ages will tell of this moment they will
sing songs of praise and direct
monuments and find a never-ending source
of hope and encouragement in this one
act this one momentous act an act that
changed the world so congratulations to
Joe
Cunningham alright um moving over to the
Republicans for a moment I'm gonna read
a little bit from a report in the hill
it says Senator Josh Holley a freshman
who has emerged as the top Republican
critic of major technology companies in
Congress on Tuesday will introduce a
bill banning social media companies from
building addictive features into their
products Holly's social media addiction
well this is what his bill is social
media addiction reduction Technology Act
or smart Act I give him credit though
for for making that acronym work it was
it was it was you bear
had to strain for it so I do like that
the Act would make it illegal for social
media platforms to hook users by
offering them more content than they
requested in order to get them to
continue on their respective platforms
the bill takes aim at practices
specifically employed by the country's
top social networking sites YouTube
Facebook Twitter and snapchat for
example with ban YouTube's autoplay
feature which loads up new videos for
users automatically it would ban
Facebook and Twitter's infinite scroll
which allows users to continue scrolling
through their home pages without limits
and it would ban snapchats
streaks which rewards users for
continuing to send photos to their
friends so it also requires the
companies to build user friendly
interfaces with features allowing users
to limit the amount of time they spend
on the platform and offering reminders
of how much time they spent perusing the
platform ok so these companies would
have to not only limit the amount of
time but they would have to build in
some sort of feature I guess I don't
know an alarm bell or something would
have to go off to let you know hey by
the way you've been on Facebook for
three and a half hours Holly said in a
statement big tech has embraced a
business model of addiction to much of
the innovation in this space is designed
not to create better products but to
capture more attention by using
psychological tricks that make it
difficult to look away
and then he goes on from there and
explains some more about what does it do
ok so I have two major problems here the
first is that the government simply has
no business getting involved here and I
know that sounds like a cliche at this
point it sounds like a libertarian
cliche just something that you say write
an assertion the government has no
business doing this but I think it's
really true in this case you take
infinite scroll for example some people
like it some people don't
I personally don't but if you're a
lawmaker and you don't personally like
something that's not enough reason to
make a law against it that's just a
taste of thing there are a lot of things
people do online that I don't like a lot
let's take for instance people who use
exclamation points too much that really
annoys me it even I would say
traumatizes me sometimes but if I was a
politician I don't
think I can make a law banning the use
of exclamation as much as I would like
to I kits I can't do that because that's
just my own personal taste which has no
business in the in the in the in the in
the law so what you have to do which is
what Holly's trying to do here is
pretend that this thing he doesn't like
is some sort of public health emergency
and I think the idea that infinite
scroll for example on Twitter is a
public health emergency is obviously
absurd second this is all justified I
mean how do you make it a public health
emergency well you say that social media
is an addiction and it's right there in
the name of the bill they put the word
addiction but I really think we need to
find other words besides addiction
addiction is ironically enough in an
abused term it seems we we grasp always
for the word addiction social media
addiction TV addictions sex addition
addiction food addiction so on and so
forth we we immediately grab for that
word addiction when sometimes a word
like compulsion or even simply habit
would be better
I can anyone whatever happened to bad
habits can anyone have a bad habit
anymore bad habits used to exist it used
to be a thing people have bad habits and
yeah it's a little bit difficult to
break a bad habit but you can do it
replace them with good habits but the
word bad you rarely hear about bad
habits anymore because everything is in
addiction anything that's a bad habit
automatically becomes an addiction
everything's an addiction the problem
though is that whatever word you use
it's obvious that a person who is who
uses a lot of social media is in a
different category from someone who uses
say a lot of heroin and the main
difference one of them anyway is that
the person using heroin the way you know
they're addicted is that if they just
stopped using it all of a sudden they
might die okay at the very least they're
going to be in the emergency room if
they just stop
there is a real a very real not not not
just psychological not but a very real
chemical need that the person on era one
has they actually need the heroin and
it's such a real need that they they
just they can't just stop they have to
be weaned off of it so it's something
through their addiction that they've
come to need but it's also killing them
that's okay there's an addiction that is
a grade-a 100% real addiction and if
they just stop all the sudden and even
in fact even if they're weaned off of it
during that process of weaning it's
going to be agonizing they're gonna be
sick they're gonna be in pain they will
experience a real withdrawal and and
they're gonna know it that's an
addiction
does a social media habit fall into that
category now you could say all you want
you could point to all the studies
showing that well if you use too much
too much social media it does this and
that bad thing to you it's a big problem
people are using too much internet I
agree I've written about that I've
talked about that I did an entire show
about it so I agree that we're all way
too much way too obsessed with our
phones and that it's it is having a
profound impact on us as people but if
the power goes out in your house and you
don't have cell reception either and so
you can't use social media for 12 hours
are you gonna be writhing on the ground
in pain are you gonna have to go to the
let me ask you this has there been
anyone I don't care how addicted you
claim somebody is to social media has
there been anyone who for some reason
was forced to go cold turkey on social
media and then ended up in the emergency
room because of the physical withdrawal
symptoms and if the answer is no and I
think the answer is no then that is not
an addiction at least it's not the saint
we need a different word we've got
heroin addiction we know what that means
we need a different word for this other
thing over here it's not the same thing
and as I said I would I would nominate
either compulsion or habit it can be
difficult to get over a compulsion could
be difficult to overcome a bad habit but
you can do it
see here's the thing somebody who is on
heroin
you can't just say to them well stop
doing it's as simple as that just stop
it's not as simple as that
but someone who uses a lot of social
media or someone who eats too much or
someone who watches too much TV or
someone watches pornography and all the
you could say to them just stop they can
stop you could tell them just stop and
they really can stop they are physically
capable of doing it it's just do they
have the incentive to stop do they have
the wherewithal do they have the moral
fortitude do they have the discipline I
mean that's what it requires to stop
doing those things or at least to to
regulate your consumption of things like
social media or food so that's the
different that is a habit and that's why
we don't need the government getting
involved because all the government
needs to say is hey people are using too
much social media maybe use less that's
it if you want to pass a bill that says
that it just encourages people to use it
less fine but I don't think it's
necessary finally here's a here's a
topic we we've talked about plenty on
this show but I have a sort of different
thought that's been in my head recently
that I want to share you know this week
the ACLU came out in support of the two
biological males who we've talked about
who have been dominating the girls track
and field circuit up in Connecticut for
two years now Terry Miller and Andrea
Yearwood are the names they go by now
with their ample supply of testosterone
and their longer legs and their greater
muscle mass and their larger lungs and
there are larger hearts and and and
innumerable other biological advantages
they've been snatching up gold medals
with times that would barely place them
in the top 20 if they're racing against
the boys it's important emphasize that
because I don't think it's a coincidence
these are mediocre male track athletes
who would not be going to States would
not be certainly wouldn't be winning
gold medals wouldn't he wouldn't even
wouldn't even be placing you know boys
track mean they go over to the girls and
they're dominating they're breaking
records are getting gold medals I don't
think that's a coincidence but the ACLU
rather than coming to the defense of the
girls who are having their metal stolen
from the Dales ACLU yesterday came out
in support of the two boys and they had
a petition where they were encouraging
us to sign a pledge of support for these
two boys who are stealing metals from
girls and this isn't the first time that
these young men have been celebrated as
heroes a few months ago maybe we talked
about on the show I can't remember
bleach or bleacher report ran a glowing
profile of Yearwood it's I mean it's
sickening to read this thing portraying
her gonna quote her as this gutsy
champion of equality when in reality
again he is just a mediocre male athlete
who decided that the best way to get a
gold medal in trophy case is to steal it
now real actual biological girls who are
having opportunities and accolades
stolen from them unfortunately you know
this is happening in high school and you
think well maybe they get to college and
they'll get a break from it but no
because there's a guy named Craig who
goes by CC now who's breaking records in
women's track at the college level but
at least these guys are merely merely
breaking records you may remember Fallon
Fox who's a biological male he was
breaking women's faces literally in MMA
before finally retiring one of his
victims one of his most recent victims
he he fractured her orbital or orbital
socket he gave her concussion she had to
get seven staples in her head because
this man was beating her senseless after
the fight she said that she felt
helpless she felt completely overpowered
which is the exact opposite of what
women are supposed this is why we
encourage girls right to get into sports
SC they're not supposed to feel
overpowered and helpless that's the
exact opposite of the sort of feeling
and experience they're supposed to have
in sports but now they go and they're
they're up against men and they feel
it's they feel helpless which they are
to a certain extent because they can't
you can't do anything about your biology
speaking of being overpowered a
professional weightlifter named Laurel
Hubbard recently decided coincidentally
that he's actually a woman after years
of competing against men he's competed
against men for years and then he and
then they said you know what I'm
actually a woman you know coincidence as
it turns out I'm a woman okay and he
went on to win gold at the Pacific Games
last week again I'm sure it's a total
coincidence that these guys mediocre
athletes discover their femininity and
then become gold medal athletes I'm sure
that I'm sure that's a total coincidence
now some people the same ones are
petitioning to prevent Hubbard from
competing and women's heavyweight events
from now on but they're meeting
resistance from the woke and enlightened
elements in society many leftists are
are opposing these people or trying to
prevent it and then many others are just
sort of ignoring it now here's my point
I I as you know I have been staunchly
opposed to the male invasion of female
sports the notion that they should be
allowed into female sports are so
self-evidently absurd that it barely
requires a rebuttal because reasonable
people do not need the issue explain to
them you go up to any normal reasonable
person no matter where they fall
politically it doesn't matter and you
ask them should biological males be
allowed to compete against girls they're
all gonna say of course not what no
that's because we know that men and
women are different we know that men
have physical advantages we know that
men don't in any meaningful sense
actually become women just because they
feel like one and they declare
themselves to be one this is all as I
said self-evident but I must admit
there's a part of me there is an
admittedly
cynical may be vengeful part of me that
as I've thought more about this issue I
start to think maybe we should just and
it pains me to even say but maybe we
should just let the left prevail on this
issue
perhaps we should allow them to do
exactly what they're trying to do
which is abolish women's sports the left
is desperately trying to destroy women's
sports to erase it get rid of it and we
as conservatives are desperately trying
to preserve it and say no we're trying
to protect women sports well what I'm
saying is maybe there's something to be
said for getting out of the way and
saying you know what fine we're gonna
sit back we're gonna kick up our feet
and we're gonna watch it happen and
we're gonna wait for the inevitable and
not far off day when the top competitors
in every women's sport are men I think
if we stopped resisting this madness I
think the time would shortly come when
when entire teams of testosterone-fueled
men are winning basketball and soccer
championships against women there would
certainly be nothing to prevent that
eventualities
if the leftists have their way so maybe
we let them have their way let them reap
what they sow let them let everybody
experience in in in the very real in a
very real and tangible way the
consequences of progressive ideology in
action because it's one thing for us to
argue about this in the abstract which
I've been doing until my face is blue
but it's another thing to see the lunacy
manifested before you in the form of say
a six foot five inch male putting up 80
points a game in women's basketball I
mean you take a you take a guy who would
be say a I don't know a sixth man in
basketball or maybe not even that you
take a guy who would make a team in the
NBA but but would hardly see any playing
time take a guy like that put him in the
NBA he's gonna get 80 points a game okay
I mean he'll be like Wilt Chamberlain
and is 100 point game except he'll do
that every game that's how fast the
disparity is and so maybe we just let
that happen it could be an educational
experience that the country needs
because I can sit here and insist that
the left's claims about gender are crazy
and destructive I think sometimes though
you know they say it's better to show
than tell well maybe we should just show
maybe we should just say alright fine
see what happens now what do you do if
your child you know you tell your child
not to touch the hot stove if he's not
gonna listen to you
eventually he's gonna have to just touch
it himself you know in my house we have
up we have a pellet stove in the
basement it's very hot
heats the house energy-efficient oh I
highly recommend it and but as I said it
gets really hot and so of course we tell
our kids don't touch the stove don't
touch the stove don't touch the stove we
keep saying it but of course eventually
our youngest one day when you know we
had our back turned he went up and
touched the stove and he got any burned
his hand into her he was fine yeah but
he recovered quickly but it really hurt
for a minute and he hasn't touched the
stove sense that was a lesson that he
just doesn't matter how many times we
said it he just needed to experience it
that for himself and he did and and and
he's fine now and he's not gonna touch
it again so maybe we're at the point
where our culture needs to just touch
the hot stove and learn the hard way and
the hard way will involve the total
dismantling of women's sports and the
undoing of nearly everything feminists
have worked for over the past several
decades that's the other irony here is
that we as conservatives are trying to
preserve the gains of feminists of
feminism while feminists hate our guts
we're the ones we're trying to help them
we're truck we're like trying to tell
them listen you these men are taking
everything from you they're undoing all
of it we're trying to help you be so
maybe we say you know what fine I have
that thought part of me thinks that way
in the end and I'm not the first person
I know people have said this to me and I
you know so I I see the appeal of that
strategy in the end I cannot fully adopt
that strategy because I know that
leftist are not going to be the ones
first and foremost punished they have
they have sort of human shields that
they're using and the human shields are
the innocent girls who are going to have
their sports taken from them so
the leftist touches the stove but it's
the innocent girls who get burned and
it's hard I can't so that's the problem
I have a daughter who might one day want
to be an athlete
why should she suffer you know why
should she be punished for the sins of
deranged leftists who are so drunk on
their ideology that they can't tell the
difference between boys and girls
anymore
I want leftist to taste their own
medicine but I don't think innocent
girls should have to taste it and so
that's the conundrum when they when they
have these girls girls like my daughter
or your daughter who they're using as
human shields what are we supposed to
I'm not sure how best to navigate it but
I will say that there is at least
something to be said for letting leftist
experience the consequence it's not
giving up it's not a surrender it's just
letting them see how crazy this actually
is something to think about and we'll
leave it there thanks everybody for
watching Godspeed if you prefer facts
over feelings if you aren't offended by
the brutal truth if you can still laugh
at the nuttiness filling our national
news cycle well tune on into the ben
shapiro show or you'll get a whole lot
of that and much more we'll see you
there